मैं हूं कैप्टन योगेंद्र सिंह यादव परमवीर
चक्र और आज बड़ा ऐतिहासिक दिन के
राष्ट्रपति भवन में एक केस परमवीर चक्र के
नाम से जो परमवीर गैलरी का इनोगेशन हो रहा
है। यह एक इनोग्रेशन नहीं बल्कि एक देश
में राष्ट्रभक्ति, राष्ट्र प्रेम, साहस,
वीरता, शौर्य की एक नई कहानी का इतिहास का
उद्घाटन हो रहा है।
आज हमारे लिए बहुत गौरव की बात है कि
राष्ट्रपति भवन में आज 21 [संगीत]
परमवीर चक्र के जो गैलरी का इनग्रेशन
राष्ट्रपति महोदय के द्वारा जो आज हो रहा
है वो पूरे देशवासियों को एक प्रेरणा का
स्रोत है।
[संगीत]
वेरी वेरी एक्साइटेड एंड प्राउड टू बी
हियर। दिस गैलरी इज अ ट्रिब्यूट टू ऑल द
परमवीर चक्र। [संगीत] इट्स अब्सोलुटली
ब्यूटीफुली मेड एंड वी वुड लाइक टू थैंक द
प्रेसिडेंट, द प्राइम मिनिस्टर फॉर सच अ
ग्रेट इनिशिएटिव [संगीत]
ऑनरिंग आवर फैमिली। देश के परमवीर चंद्रा
जिन्होंने [संगीत] देश के लिए अपनी जानों
को न्योछावर किया है उनके नाम पर यह रखे
हैं। यह मेरे ख्याल से [संगीत] युवा पीढ़ी
को प्रेरित करने के लिए इससे अच्छा कोई और
कदम नहीं हो सकता।
[संगीत]